معنى من بيروت الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجيه العميد الياس حنا ست العميل
ما قراءتك للمشهد خاصه في الجبهه الشرقيه
عثمان الجيش الاوكراني حاليا يعاني في
الهجوم العكسي خاصه في منطقه الجنوب وحتى
باتجاه مليتو بول وما شابه المكان الوحيد
الذي يمكن تحقيق تقدم او انجاز في حاليا
هو بخموت لماذا لانها لا تزال استمرار
لعمليه الحرب التي قادها بيجوجين او فاجنر
يعني انسحاب اوكرانيا قدوم فاقنر بعدها
خروج فجنر وقدوم عسكري جديد الى منطقه
وهذا امر يعنينا بمعنى وعي المكان والزمان
خاصه الميدان والتكتيكي وبالتالي اليوم
الجيش الاوكراني يعيد المسار العكسي
لفاغنر يعني التقدم من الجنوب الغربي ومن
الشمال الغربي لتطويق المنطقه واذا تحقق
هذا الموضوع هذه ضربه للجيش الروسي
للمعنويات وبالتالي تثبيت لمصداقيه
بريكوجين في مرحله لاحقه ماذا عن الحديث
عن استخدام مرتزقه جدد لا ينت الى الى
فاجنر كيف نفهم خطوه هذه هنا هناك دائما
هناك ضمن الجيش الروسي منذ بدات هذه الحرب
عده جيوش متوازيه مع بعضها البعض فاقنر
حاليا هي في وضع الشلل ووضع اعاده التنظيم
هناك قوات الشيشانيه رمضان خديروف
وبالتالي هناك يقل ان هناك شركه تابعه
لشركه غاز بروم بدا تحضيرها او حتى شركات
خاصه اخرى هذا الهدف
للقياده الروسيه ان لا يكون هناك مسؤوليه
مباشره او فعلا تخفيف الاعباء على الجيش
وبالتالي استخدام مقاتلين ذات خبره عاليه
الى منطقه حساسه وبالتالي ليس من مسؤوليات
سياسيه وحتى اجتماعيه في الداخل الروسي
لانه الموضوع هو موضوع التعاقد ومبالغ
كثيره تدفع وهي برضا من يقاتل هل تطورات
المعركه تثبت كان على حق وان كانت الاجابه
بن عم فباي معنى واي سياق
وهل يبدو ان طرفا من الطرفين قادر على
تحقيق انتصار
عندما نتحدث عن بخمه عثمان نتحدث عن
كريمينا
بخموت وبالتالي اوغلادار ووصولا ان هذه
الجبهه المتواصله مع بعضها البعض ان يتم
ان يتم سيطره روسيه هذا امر يثبت ما فعله
وان خساره ضخمه هي ضربه معنويه للجيش
وكانه يقول بطريقه غير مباشره ان من يقاتل
بفعلا بقوه وله خبره هو فقط وليس الجيش
الروسي العادي وهذا يثبت مصداقيته تجاه
انتقاداته لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه شكرا
جزيلا العميد الياس حنا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي